a typhoon has slammed into the eastern
Philippines as authorities struggle to
evacuate hundreds of thousands of people
but many of the emergency shelters are
overcrowded with no means of social
distancing and without poppers proper
safety gear against the coronavirus
typhoon vongfong
is expected to sweep across densely
populated areas before exiting in the
north on sunday typhoon vongfong is
packing powerful sustained winds of up
to 150 kilometers per hour so far no
deaths have been reported but it's still
putting millions of lives at risk
because of the corona virus pandemic
areas hit by the typhoon under lockdown
and people are trying to stay home to
avoid infection the authorities have
evacuated around 200,000 people who now
face contracting the virus at
overcrowded emergency shelters due to
social distancing measures the shelters
can only accept half the capacity and
people have to wear face masks but not
everyone has one and many are trying
their best to keep safe now we have a
lack of supplies for face masks that's
why we have started to make our own ones
to avoid the spread of the virus
typhoons are common occurrences in the
Philippines but this time the corona
virus outbreak has made the threat even
worse the national weather agency warns
of potential flooding and landslides in
the coming days now from Manila ECW's
Ana Santos and as we heard there the
typhoon a cycle has already ravaged
several islands in the Philippines what
is the situation now
government officials told me today that
managing a typhoon in the middle of a
pandemic is a nightmare so thousands
have been evacuated into evacuation
centers and this took a longer time than
usual and they had to transport people
and vehicles that were only operating at
half capacity and then taking
temperature checks and then trying to
distribute as many face smack face masks
as they could among the evacuees now
additionally to that we've started
seeing pictures from the affected areas
we saw devastation thousands of people
living in the coastal communities have
now seen their houses just completely
flattened so after the typhoon this now
brings us to another problem these
people these evacuees might not have a
home to return to and how will they stay
safe in the coronavirus after that and
these disaster response teams I mean
they they have this challenge now of of
still operating despite the corona virus
pandemic slowing their work down how are
they managing this emergency this
typhoon is really straining government
resources and manpower that have already
been really hard strapped since the
lockdown that we've been under for the
last two months so the the bigger
challenge now is managing hygiene and
sanitation in this very cramped
evacuation center they're notorious for
not being able to have sanitation and
hygiene in the first place now also the
next couple of days we'll be monitoring
the typhoon hitting the capital of
Manila we've seen over half of the total
for bid positive cases in Manila and
this is mostly because of how densely
populated Manila is these dense this
density this overcrowding of Manila is
what you see mirrored in the evacuation
centers so government authorities are
really now facing two challenges how to
protect people from the typhoon and how
to prevent these evacuation centers from
turning into hot
for Corona bye corona virus infection
okay
DW XANA Santos joining us from Manila
where this typhoon is forecast to hit
shortly thank you so much